it is time
to play
horizon forbidden west which i think
looks absolutely beautiful
um this is obviously my first time
playing it we're gonna do what i
normally do which is a first hour
of gameplay which i kind of treat like a
preview as well just give my first
impressions
um
contrast seems fine to me
yeah i've been really looking forward to
this
um
looks like they made a lot of like very
significant improvements i'm excited to
swim underwater
just the way the environment looks a
lifetime
spent in the pursuit of knowledge
one question consumed me
how did our world come to be
great question
nobody knows
the old ones perished a thousand years
ago
triggering the extinction
of all life
she
showed me how it was reborn
what a beautiful voice he has this girl
of her own importance
through her
i learned that life was only saved
through a technological miracle
zero dawn
a terraforming system composed of nine
subordinate functions
each
playing its part to reshape earth from a
barren rock
to a lush landscape it's cool that they
include this recap because i imagine a
fair number of people will jump into um
the machines i jump into this game
without having played the first one
it has a very good story i'm a big fan
of this plot
a lot going on
i learned the deepest secret of them all
the secret
of her birth
that she is a clone of elizabeth
zero dawn's creator
born to prevent a new extinction
spoilers obviously
but not for this game driven by
a malevolent ai
given sentence by a mysterious signal
of unknown origin
and with a little help from me
she prevailed in a great battle at the
city of meridian
she sure did
becoming a champion for all humankind
but as useful as she has been
now
i must leave her behind
for she strives but right what haiti
sundered
i have made a new discovery
one that heralds both destruction
and opportunity his voice oh my gosh
i wonder if you get tired speaking like
that
oh that's interesting so what i'm
looking at right now is let me just have
my camera
explorer and guided so explorer is
minimal heart information look at the
world to find a way guided as markers
and icons on screen to assist you on
your journey
so i had seen people get angry because
one reviewer played the game on it was
either normal or hard but on the
explorer difficulty and people took that
to mean
he was playing uneasy which i guess he
wasn't good to know um
i'm gonna go with explorer that sounds
like the more challenging one
auto saves will take place frequently as
you progress
each quest step manual saves may be made
at campfires
i thought the dog queen she's okay let's
do it let's go
[Music]
i love the jewel sense i feel like i say
it every time anytime it does anything
i'm like wow the greatest controller
ever i'm such a big fan of the
of the
the rumbles the haptic feedback
[Music]
i'm running out of time elizabeth
the land is dying
people are suffering
soon
i'll starve pretty big bubba pretty big
bubble bit of an l
oh because of a terraforming system
that's spiraling out of control
and only i
can fix it
only i have your genetic code
it won't be long before we hit the point
and then extinction
i've been searching for months for what
i need
a backup of gaia
the aiu designed to control the system
but every time i think i have a lead
damn huh
capsule looks incredible
and every night i have the same dream
i do feel like it's been like quite a
minute since we've had
through a gameplay of flowers
and when i arrive at the center
i see you elizabeth
waiting for me
even though you've been
dead for a thousand years
you're the closest person i've ever had
to a mother
harsh but fair
[Music]
her hair looks awesome
and for a moment
i feel whole
[Music]
but it never lasts
how beautiful the colors
it's already so vivid
oh no
dude if the game looks like this that is
beautiful i'm always left alone
this world is your legacy elizabeth
i won't let it slip away
oh my god you can fully see the hairs on
her face
the valley below is my only remaining
lead
my last hope to find the backup
i'll do whatever it takes to get it
oh my god promise
okay well okay now we all know that it
is a lot more difficult than that to put
a necklace on
have you it takes me like 10 minutes
if it is an alien the savior of meridian
and anointed of the nora you know i hate
being called that stuff well consider it
a punishment for running out on us the
very same night we beat hades
sucks when your friends leave you off
you behave
not much for parties
yeah
that one was in your honor
just saying
it's a hard game you know
what are we doing
super giant uh so fast
make great games make great games
dry joke i'm making i'm so sorry
i have a problem it has something to do
with the blight
both actually but um
i shouldn't oh no
i've been tracking you a long way it's
okay
after everything you've done to help the
nora and my family i swore an oath to
help you no matter what you're stuck
with me now
like bark on wood
what
what does that mean
is that a
saying
okay
but
if you're going to come with me
you'll need to be able to see what i see
a focus
never thought i'd get your second sight
i'll give you another one later and show
you how to back up your data
data
information
on the device we've got a lot to cover
um i'll have to explain it to me trying
to explain uh what a url is to my
parents
it's it's the link what
don't worry about it it's fine
[Music]
you see like this all the time since i
was a little girl
come on
it does seem cool surely we're not that
far away from those though i think those
are the same as the chips that are
killing monkeys thanks to elon musk
surely it's the same thing
shall we
give gameplay
gameplay
i would like to video game the video
game
all right i've become a lot less
tolerant of that every time it's on the
way here with too many cut scenes we
should find someone we could be doing
stuff while we have these chats
so it's time for your first lesson with
the focus sounds good it's a good way to
do this tutorial it's like she's
teaching someone else
not a bad idea
these plants don't look like the ones in
the sacred lands
the focus helps you see the ones are you
joking
oh my god it's beautiful
okay hang on let me check um
what
mode i'm playing in
i'm gonna go with performance
oh you can change the alignment of the
camera that's cool
okay
there those plants by the stream should
do the trick
dude
okay noted i just hit the
i hit r2 to try to run because i've been
playing so much sifu
didn't work out
oh my gosh
also diagolate 2 starts off the same way
sometimes you just gotta go to gather
some medicines you know
and swim
maybe i'm trying a little bit too soon
huh
[Music]
dude
the colors
my gosh
is he doing anything to help
it's a blades of grass
what on earth swim it's a waterfall if
there's nothing behind it then the video
game is dead to me
dead to me that's it i'm done
oh hello how did you get over there
oh my hello sir
we should keep going okay where are we
going
damn i want to grab more
yeah good idea
that tracks
um the ancient ruins is this way
that's what i thought i would have to do
aha okay
ground stained red
the blight must be infecting the soil
i'm supposed to do something with that
there we go okay
some of the gliders
it's peeling off
dead skin
is that how it spreads it's a lot of
particles
oh my god look at this
those ruins that's where we need to go
i see a few ways down
what are we after exactly dude
oh my god oh excuse me ai
it's um
it's hard to explain
think of it like
a set of instruments if they keep this
up this has to be one of the best
looking open wall games ever made oh i
should have gone for the zip line huh
oh man
cool it feels good
and looks good obviously
i don't remember how to descend um
okay squares go down
oh dude
wow
wow wow wow wow stunning
stunning and brave stunning and brave
um okay
go to the ancient ruins
i just
oh my god
salvaging machine purposes
looks like they left a carcass behind
probably should have been looting the
whole way but whatever i got plans i'm
busy
what the hell
swipe up the pole ah i like that that's
cool
oh oh stairs are always a good test do
they walk up the steps individually or
do they walk through them
i mean it's pretty close
excuse me sir
it's it's
sometimes she's walking on air
but it's pretty damn close stairs are
difficult
a lot of arrows in that machine
better take a closer look
someone took down this machine recently
who else would come here
i don't know
we better craft some mirrors of our own
that might be trouble or bad
there's some ridgewood by the stream
dude
this is nuts okay you can see some
textures repeat up there in the
waterfall that's okay look at the amount
of detail
jesus christ
uh what do you need me to do
it's ball
hello
don't mind if i do all right
now to craft some moves
i could really keep wanting to hold on
to
but i belong
i'm just gonna take it all ooh a car
uh weapon wheel
done beautiful me too
arrows ready
my god am i going to spend the whole
game just being shocked by the way it
looks
jeez
so dense man i wish i knew other words
it's always my go-to the density
thank you thank you
i bet you people are going to come up
some beautiful photos
when this uh photo mode comes out
by the goddess just stunning
absolutely stunning what was this place
i don't know
the transmission
the uh
message i found
didn't say
only that a backup might be here
i need to find a way in
so um
what happened after i
left maria
well there was a fuss when people
realized you were gone
but then some of us figured you only
would have left if it were for something
important
[Music]
i too just like to keep my foot on a fox
it's not just poisoning plants
that's killing animals too
then people will get sick too
and starve
you're not gonna let that happen
just trying to scope it out you know
what i'm saying
the sound is pretty incredible too
i know i'm just taking a look
damn
i cannot imagine how long it took to put
this amount of detail in
while
it's like is the whole world like this
down this way
that's my question because i'm guessing
we're not even in the forbidden west
just yet get to the cross
yeah touch gross besties
the focus can help us
okay see how parts of it are glowing
those are its weak spots
i don't really have much
detachable attack removal destroyed when
killed
[Music]
it's a weak spot okay
who would have guessed
we needed to look over here though
oh this is optional
i'm sorry mate i'm doing it
i'm sorry my friend i don't feel great
about it either
a lot of arrows
no
hello mate
i just think he's really cute
oh yeah i could just do a
run up here
that's very slow but i think we saw in
one of the gameplay previews that you
it's like a hunter i like the animation
that animation is very pretty though
it just yeah
feels heavy um yeah i'm pretty sure that
you get all the other weapons well as
soon as the celebration was over my
mother led the rest of the nora home
sun king put his people to work
rebuilding the city and i set out to
find you
hello mate
you have found me you are welcome
someone shot this machine too
i have a um
projector screen in my bedroom that i've
been playing um my second
ghost of tsushima playthrough on
i feel like i might do this game too
like stuff that
the environments look like this is just
so nice on a huge screen
i thought that i could walk in ladder at
the same time but we are not there yet
one step at a time
okay that's good
oh
man
you said you've out of focus since you
were a child right
yeah
i found my first one when i found to a
ruin
got the others from an old cache not
long ago
it's good to have extras
does that some pop in maybe who cares
though really
welcome to the far zenith launch
facility
thank you
i know they made some tech trades with
zero dawn but
why would they have a backup of gaia
please register with reception for the
tour i'm trying i guess they want us to
check in with them
i would love
to please hold for identiscan
access denied
please wait here for personnel to assist
you dr sobek
okay
i guess they weren't on great terms with
elizabeth a little bit let's find a way
in i wonder if there's anyone named that
surely
excuse me mate
yeah i feel like we stand a pretty good
chance of just walking on it
i will not access denied
credentials not recognized
by me then like me either
i didn't think that would work but you
always got to give it a shot you know
you always you always got to give it a
shot
i should be able to pry this open okay
let's do it
that is a strong weapon
there's climbing gear
yes someone dropped in from above
whoever left this here might have also
shot those machines we found earlier
they're close by where are they now
they gotta be
ugh
what's that stench
the entire camp
wiped out
oh damn i must have come here for scrap
acid
that explains the smell
yikes somebody poured acid on them big
came in from above
crashed right through the camp
oh
we should take a look at the rubble in
that gap
we should take a look at the rubble in
that gap okay
i'm being honest i wouldn't have checked
that if she hadn't upset you i would
have assumed that was just
the game while telling me where i can't
go if i can dislodge some of the debris
we might be able to squeeze through
maybe i can find something to help in
the camp
hey over here
i think i got something what'd you get
a corpse
oh you're a freak some kind of awesome
prototype i think
this hook looks like it can latch onto
things
and the scare pulls it back
it looks broken but maybe we can repair
it hook it to the debris
and pull it out
that could work
the focus can help us search the camp
and identify anything we can use to fix
the tool
my focus picked up a couple of things to
check out is this gonna hurt us
probably right if i touch it it'll let
me
hello what are you
right through his armor
what you got
part of a machine
could help fix the gears
oh
what was this
sorry mate
um
anything else
ah
i'm so curious if i run in it what would
happen but i won't i won't i went i
won't
i will wait
machine cable
stronger than rope all right i think i
have what i need to remove the tool
or maybe even
repair the tool she says
what uh what tool am i repairing
um
something over here all right i think i
have what i need to repair the tool
or maybe even make something better
maybe make something better
i see the workbench okay
pull caster an improved version of a
delvers prototype tool that can latch
onto and pull objects also enables
grappling to specific points let's do it
hell yeah grapple
okay
there
uh pull caster
now to test it on the debris
let's check it out
wall cluster is a versatile tool that
allows you to manipulate objects in the
environment and have a graded pattern
okay
um
i thought so
there you go
okay we have to be pretty specific about
that i guess
what now i'm gonna do more of it
probably
okay
oops wrong button i just completely
forgot everything
okay you gotta pull the red i guess
nice that works better than i thought
well it doesn't look like there's an
easy way out of here
i should scan the area
so i have to find a way to keep going
huh
what's this thing for great question
couldn't tell you
forget what you think you know about us
our truth wouldn't think you know
we say reach for the stars even if you
have to cross 8.6 light years of space
to get there
please proceed into the auditorium
me too my friend but first we run around
and we scan okay we've done it i feel
like i did
a pretty good sweep
um can this be pulled
probably not right maybe climbable
no any luck
not yet
but scanning the area with my focus
activated might show me
something
i hope that while i'm obviously getting
lost i hope that it doesn't tutorialize
quite that much
i'm missing something
um like if she talks that much it could
get a little
bit cumbersome i feel
i can fit through there come on
okay fine fine
oh up there i see okay
oh this is going to be
to
grapple yeah oh you need me to okay i'll
scan it fast i might be able to get up
there yeah and then
it's
uh
this and then this
i don't think i'm doing this right
no
no cancel
um it's jump and tap x so we just
what
neat
that works
that pull caster is useful
don't worry i'll find you another way up
nah see ya
we good i don't need no man
it's very intuitive
if it is literally just it'll know to
pull out x anytime the uni is something
that can do it that's that's very simple
nice
hey no worries mate any time
lost or heavily shielded seal integrity
maintained
never mind i don't mind if i did
humans homo sapiens
us
we have always pushed the boundary as
explorers pioneers trailblazers
and now far zenith is taking the next
leap into the future
that's why we're proud to have
resurrected the
our government's odyssey
in orbit far zenith will actualize in
less than a decade hmm but that's only
the beginning
when the ship is complete we will send
the odyssey and her crew where no one's
[Music]
it's certainly visually exciting i'm so
excited for that vr game like this nvr
would be awesome and i know the vr game
isn't pretending to do this in vr but
um but when we look up at the night sky
we'll know they're on their way
and in the words of our founder the late
peter chimbrombe
the truth
where's his face
stopped
not a great vibe
between the stars
uh
well
yes
sort of
that ship
the odyssey
it never made it to the other star
something went wrong and it blew up
[Music]
ah that's why we came here come on we
have to reactivate oh sure reactivate
oh i'm sorry it's been too exciting
sorry darling hello i live pretty girl
oh i'm sorry
you having a good nap i got too excited
and we're talking about the projections
economic instability
new bio contagions
rampant ais
how long before another catastrophe
creates unacceptable risk for the
world's elite
we here at far zenith believe
escape the inevitable
and so we reach for the stars
those look like a satellite now you've
seen what we're building here
to support the odyssey's construction
a state-of-the-art data center to
facilitate rapid technological
advancements
and you've seen how we're managing
public perception
so invest
and join us
claim your birth on the odyssey
preserve your way of life beyond the
concerns of earth
well they were right about the world
ending i just didn't know how
yet
yeah so everything they said back there
about the next step for humanity
it was all a lie
these people only cared about saving
their own skin
yeah well
it didn't work out for them in the end
that oldfall guy mentioned a data center
it's such a unique
that it feels like we're seeing the past
in the future at the same time
it's very
cool thing about the this new horizon
series
i guess it's a series now also i should
make myself a little bit smaller
and probably move myself to the other
side
let me just readjust because i think you
get stuff on that bottom left so let me
i still can't believe the old ones can
fly i'll be right here that seems good
they were capable of a lot of things
for good and bad
sure seems like it
i wonder what it's like up there
among the stars
the wilds have really grown over this
place
i like that
ancient supply chest
and another one
thank you
oh this is gonna
be pullable right
that was like an explosion okay
beautiful okay
damn
oh my god
playstations just make beautiful games i
don't want those things like all the
playstation studios games are just
stunning
you take the left one aldi with the one
on the right also she has shockingly
good eyebrows for somebody who lives in
an apocalypse
moving
off i need to sneak up on it to take it
out with my spear
i can't let it see me you see nothing i
should scan it first
i just feel like that like way it's
animated is so
cute so i know i probably shouldn't
think but i sure do
um
do you want me to
grab
the rock
come back
um
how to throw rock i do not recall
rock
just that
it's like a little ferret
i know that i'm
not supposed to find it cute but i do
yeah i find you cute
oh one is highlight track
keep going on your track one
keep moving
there you go
oh it hadn't occurred to me that the
other one could see me
i thought that that would be long grass
that's fine
oh
oh because i failed i mean i took the
the break to like dog let me try again
pick up rock
i can throw a rock to distract it
get it into a position where i can sneak
up and strike
just have to wait for the right moment
time to throw
oh why didn't it work i would have
thought that would work okay
i really just want to shoot it i want i
want it's fine i want
strike
i'm sorry my friend i'm sorry
i'm sorry
alright peabody
it's so cute
nice nice nice nice
she's so like
she's so climby you know it's great
all right
more of those machines ahead
nothing you and i can't handle
probably
oh god i forgot how to crouch
i think it's i think it's it's square my
bad my bad my bad no you don't
but i don't really want to steal oh
that's why we need to stealth them
because i don't really want to still
fight them i just want to fight them
[Music]
is there a dodge mechanic of something
i don't know
excuse me a second i'm just taking stuff
just give me a moment please
little ferret friends i apologize
a little bit up his tail
because they're not hard to kill you
know
so i'm fine with though i guess i am
running outta notice you have a medicine
look these days
yeah i know didn't have a lot of time to
shave so easy to find that's up to you i
prefer to despite them that's something
that's not permanent
good
sorry my whiskers offend you anointed
well hush
hey
i will say i don't love i mean this game
is beautiful combat super fun i don't
love
games that that um
and it's it's kind of my own fault make
me especially reliant on tracking all
the time
which i am certainly doing oh welcome
back
welcome back i don't want to let you out
and you came back anyway
hello
[Music]
hello
dog has returned must give dog pat break
you understand how it is priorities
okay you think it's pretty
huh
the lights made its way in here too
oh there's a corpse there
of what
[Music]
oh whatever i just touched with slimy oh
i'll take your word for it
maybe i was meant to look at the fox
what a lot of folks action looks like
this little guy got caught up in the
blight
i couldn't escape
i hope it didn't suffer long
[Music]
the officer must have used explosives
against the machines they managed to get
a couple
this is so consistently beautiful does
the whole game stay like this because
geez
must have broken through
it's ridiculous
do you need did you come back in here
because you need something
hello hello
you're okay
you're all right she's probably hungry
actually it's about dinner time we
should feed her
soon there's gotta play more it's eloy
you love alice for later
i've decided to have a chance to use it
careful traps ahead
i might be able to disarm them
there
managed to salvage some supplies
and not blow yourself up and got more
supplies
the physics are actually really
impressive
it's cool
um okay
i want you to craft some blast traps do
you
where's the what
i must kill them both
uh the work bench or i guess yeah do it
on my crafting screen
[Music]
oh i don't have the right supplies to
craft a trap
okay but it looks like the awesome shot
off some machine parts
i might be able to scrounge up enough
materials from them
cool
i can use this lost paste
it's an accident but i still love it it
looks awesome because i just keep trying
to run
too much seafood i've played like 15
hours of seafood
and now we go down
and then
craft
there
explosive trap made wonderful if
anything walks into one of those
i won't know what hit it
i do not have any wild meat you're not
wrong
she really does want to scan everything
um
i guess they're on you
i've seen this machine before
it's new to me
let's see where its weak points are
maybe we could place one of those traps
you made in his path
that's not a terrible idea
out of that tap to select floss trap
place on ground
oh nope
nope took medication hang on there we go
and now we're gonna place
come back
that one source but that's okay
we'll be fine
come on
oh highlight your track
watch out dude
that could have killed you my man
yikes
he's just right there it was an
explosion
my god okay
they sound like dogs but they look like
kind of like wasps
super interesting
okay did it go
come on man
i wonder if it hurts me if i'm close to
it
clearly it doesn't help my friend
and there it is
we're clear all right let's keep going
thank you
you've been in a lot of old her hair
looks so good oh they all like this
they all have their secrets but
every place is different
i love that they show her struggling
with some things like it's not just
totally effortless it's cool
that's a big storm picking up out there
is it
yeah that's exciting and they're getting
stronger
i'm more frequent
so the storms the blighted lands the
rivers and lakes choked with algae
you were born to fix all that
yeah
i'd only do
but first we must interact with whatever
this is there's data here
you've scanned it with your focus
thank you
this data mentions the tech that farzee
has traded with zero dawn
it doesn't explain how they got a backup
i'll keep an eye out for more data
that's such a funny concept i'll keep an
eye out for more data what a lot of
glyphs okay
i'll talk just a way to study later
looks like we've got to climb up
i suppose we do okay
falling apart
well it is a thousand years old
fair
it old
all right
it looks like some kind of meeting room
a door on the other side
bonzo
empowered by nine subordinate functions
gaia the core of the system
is capable of advanced planetary
engineering
an obvious advantage to our space
colonization efforts
operation phase one establish an asset
within project zero dawn status complete
phase two the asset will secretly beam
cast a complete copy of gaia and her
subordinate functions to this facility's
data center if all goes well zero dawn
staff will remain completely hmm
then expect that discovery of this
operation could result in zero dawn
withholding the already negotiated
apollo database
special care must be taken not to alert
travis state the expert hacker in charge
of hades protocol
in addition extreme caution must be
exercised that's why i didn't have a
access
as one of the world's preeminent
technologists she may have instituted
unforeseen security measures
a complete assessment is attached this
concludes the executive summary
it seems like it was a little bit too
easy to access this high security
information if i'm being
here
but she didn't
far zenith stole gaia
eloy
why does that woman look like you
um
it's okay bro
we
look alike because
we're the exact same
genetically identical but she was one of
the old ones
how can you be her
because i
wasn't born
i was
mate
i'm not a fan of the way that she's
emoting there it's a lot of hands
motherless why i
was cast out as an infant
i don't understand
what kind of machine can make a person
remember when i said the backup is like
a set of instructions it's
more than that
it's called gaia
and for a long time she cared for the
world until she had to
destroy herself
so she made
me
to bring her back
i'm the only one who can
and this place
is my last hope
until we go to san francisco you once
said the goddess spoke to you when you
went into all mother mountain
was that this
gaia
yes but
she's not the goddess
there isn't one how can you be sure
it sounds like she anointed you with a
sacred taste may as well be
i've had a lot of time to figure this
out and you will too
with the focus but for now
the reports said they were going to
store the stolen copy of gaia in the
data center
so that's where we have to go
okay
it's a lot to unpack it's a lot to
unpack
like your whole well just came crashing
down on you i'm not mad at him for
having a couple of cute little questions
i thought that would be where i would
have to go
oh
look at that
over here
i found something i love things that i
can use
those oscar must have left us behind a
weapon
thanks fall
we should keep moving
after you
blast links launch bombs that affect
large areas this weapon fires frost
bombs use them against enemies to build
up the brittle state well in brittle
state enemies are more vulnerable to
impact damage cool
down here
i think we're almost back outside
damn dude
i'm excited about the storm the sky box
okay
um l1 weapon wheel
[Music]
this one
they didn't stand a chance
looks like we can cross over here
oh my god it's so pretty i'm sorry if
that's repetitive i'm just so impressed
beautiful um but i think i should leave
it there this backup is the last one
we're back out heading to the backup i
might try and stream some of the games
um coming up in these last few months
i'm
currently like supposed to be overall
like even more impressed than i expected
to be and we haven't even been to like
the super pretty parts of the game yet
it definitely feels similar to the first
game
um
i don't yeah i don't love how much i
make myself rely on scanning
environments and then collecting stuff
i'll try and like get myself out of that
though i feel like i've just played so
many games we have to do that
you just scan and pick up scan and pick
up whereas like this is so much prettier
i'm a big fan of the law so there's a
lot to love here definitely
um
it's super interesting and just just
absolutely beautiful
also yeah the combat feels great
that is that is my first impressions
of horizon forbidden west
um let me know if you want to see more
i'll probably stream it on twitch
twitch.tv slash channel amazon thank you
guys watching i'll see you next time
[Music]